son nom en disait le mais le projet de
menhirs landes où le pays des menhirs en
terre bretonne c'est du passé
enterré dans sa version d'origine par le
ministre de la culture lui même mais pas
complètement abandonné le réaménagement
du site de karnak et de ses 3000 menhirs
et autres dolmen doit être reconsidéré
trop d'incohérences qu'on fasse
disparaître parce qu'on est dans ainsi
protéger des éléments des constructions
médiocre en taule en parpaings bon c'est
sans doute indispensable mais on fasse
disparaître des maisons paysannes témoin
de l'exploitation agricole du site ça me
semblerait vraiment une contre contre
vérités flagrantes expropriation de
riverains déviation d'une route
mais ce sont également des boutiques une
cafétaria un hall d'accueil de 1600
mètres carrés et un immense parking qui
était envisagé coût prévu de l'opération
16 millions d'euros
depuis onze ans le menhir landes
déchaîne les passions les défenseurs de
l'environnement et ceux de l'identité
bretonne meliet farouchement contre ce
qu'ils considèrent comme un jackpot
touristique qui propose l'état français
1991 il en convient lui même d'ailleurs
c'est fait en dehors de toute
concertation avec aussi bien les
populations au tac avec les visiteurs
le ministre promet de mieux respecter
l'environnement est également d'inviter
les associations locales et les
carnacois à l'élaboration d'un nouveau
projet une proposition devrait lui être
remises d'ici trois mois